[Musique]
je faisais des crises de panique sur la
glace et moi c'est vraiment c'est devenu
une chercher aussi physiquement
je pourrais tomber à nouveau un premier
effort intense
antoine gélinas-beaulieu les patineurs
de vitesse
ces jours ci il participe aux jeux
olympiques de beijing
il revient de loin
arrive un moment où je faisais vraiment
une crise d'asthme j'aurais dû être
hospitalisé puis mon coach et ryad - le
pendant des années il a subi de la
violence psychologique au sein de
l'équipe nationale de courte piste
le sujet premier entraînement de l'année
faisait face est sa squat d'une james
est ça soit dow jones et des
entraînements qui font aucun sens même
si les physiothérapeutes qui font partie
de l'équipe disent ça vaut blessés les
athlètes le titre tu peux pas faire ça
elles sont les physiothérapeutes ont pas
écoutés ils sont mis de côté puis on
fait faire les entraînements communs
en 2012 il a accroché ses patins
mais sa bataille contre l'anxiété et la
dépression ne faisait que commencer à
chaque fois j'en parle on dirait que ça
choque les gentils de hawaii un athlète
c'est ça peut vivre ça
[Musique]
de l'athlète antoine gélinas-beaulieu
est loin d'être seul
à
l'université de toronto grainger enquête
sur la maltraitance vécue par les
athlètes de haut niveau
le phénomène de la maltraitance est
aussi important que celui du dopage
et c'est encore plus difficile de s'y
attaquer
en 2021 son équipe a publié les
résultats d'un sondage mené auprès de
membres actuels ou retraités des équipes
nationales au canada mais l'athlète de
soixante quatre disciplines ont répondu
75 % des athlètes qu'on dit avoir vécu
au moins un incident de violence
psychologique
mais surtout 25% c'est un quart ont
indiqué qu'ils avaient subi des
agressions psychologiques de façon
répétée
parmi les agressions les plus souvent
rapportées il y avait subir des cris de
colère
est repoussé à s'entraîner lorsque
blessés épuisés
se faire rabaisser ou humilie
être ignorée à la suite d'une mauvaise
performance
et
les agressions sexuelles d'athlètes ont
généré beaucoup d'attention médiatique
et à juste titre mais c'est la violence
psychologique qui est la plus courante
dans le monde du sport
majoritairement les athlètes ont pointé
leur entraîneur lorsqu'on leur a demandé
d'où venaient les agressions
il n'y avait pas une journée où j'étais
en sécurité
chaque fois que j'arrivais à la piscine
j'avais mal au ventre je ne savais pas
qu'elle mme ou dégradants elle allait
m'adresser
erin wasson est étudiante au doctorat
dans l'équipe de gretchen craint
pendant sept ans elle a fait partie de
l'équipe nationale de natation
artistique elle a été victime
d'intimidation à cause de son physique
ce qu'on appelle le badische hemming en
anglais
son entraîneuse lui répétait 116 que
l'était trop grosse
j'avais un demi kilo au dessus de la
limite prescrite on m'a retiré de
l'équipe si je voulais retrouver ma
place je devais perdre le plus de points
possible
j'étais en compétition contre une autre
fille celle qui perdait le plus de kilos
pourrait participer aux championnats
mondiaux
erin wasson a retrouvé sa place au sein
de l'équipe nationale mais elle a perdu
son équilibre
j'ai perdu pied après ça tout ce qui
m'intéressait c'était mon poids parce
qu'on me disait que c'était la seule
chose qui comptait
dans le cadre de son doctorat l
interview d athlète féminine qui comme
elle ont fait partie des équipes
nationales où le corps et contrôler et
évaluer
une athlète a raconté qu'elle n'avait
pas le droit de boire de l'eau pendant
les entraînements parce qu'elle serait
trop lourde et ne pourrait pas sauter
aussi haut
toutes les athlètes qu'elle a
interrogées ont développé des troubles
de l'alimentation
bike psychologique je continuais pas
système au quotidien c'était mon rêve
aussi je savais que si j'arrêtais
qu'allait prendre ma place je
n'ai pas recevoir plus d'argent des fois
j'allais juste à être laissée à l'oubli
les études scientifiques sur la
maltraitance dans le sport est dit que
les athlètes de haut niveau en sont plus
souvent victimes
mais le phénomène existe aussi chez les
plus jeunes on est allé voir l'ensemble
des formes de violence vécue par les
jeunes athlètes de 14 à 17 ans qui était
actif au moment où nos questions
sylvie parent et spécialiste des
questions de violence dans le sport à
l'université laval et non le des
chiffres tournent autour de 79 % des
athlètes les jeunes athlètes qui ont
vécu au moins une forme de violence
psychologique par leur cheminement
sportif on a des chiffres qui tourne
autour de 28 % pour la violence sexuelle
qui majoritairement du harcèlement
sexuel et où la violence physique on
tourne autour de 30 9%
l'un des principaux facteurs de risque
selon ses vues par an c'est la
spécialisation hâtives c'est à dire le
fait de s'investir exclusivement dans un
sport avant l'âge de 12 ans et de le
pratiquer plus de huit mois par année
les jeunes font peut-être plus isolé
quand ils pratiquent énormément de leur
personnel beaucoup plus en contact
évidemment avec une équipe qui est autre
que ils n'avaient que leurs parents qui
sont amenés à se déplacer aussi dans les
compétitions des camps d'entraînement
etc
les études de sylvie parent et sont à
mettre en perspective
les milliers d'athlètes qui ont reçu les
sondages et est libre d'y répondre ou
pas cela crée forcément un billet on
peut penser que les athlètes victimes de
violences étaient plus susceptibles de
répondre
il reste que les chiffres sont alarmants
c'est la violence psychologique dans le
monde du sport est si répandue c'est
parce que les normaliser malheureusement
on va utiliser la violence psychologique
dans le but d'entraîner les athlètes de
les amener à performer mieux que ce soit
en voulant les motiver en voulant créer
chez eux la résilience donc soit plus
fort mentalement et compagnie
les athlètes acceptent ces comportements
il croit que ça va les aider à atteindre
le podium ou à réaliser leurs rêves ils
apprennent à vivre avec
dans l'anc est
moins de 15% des athlètes qui avaient
vécu de la violence avait dénoncé les
abus
ce qu'ils avaient vécu de la violence
psychologique ne considérait pas que
c'était de la bulle
avec les autres formes de violence les
athlètes ne savait pas où se tourner
plus encore ils craignaient les
répercussions
accès à la roma 0 le psychologue sportif
qui est elle n était pas un psychologue
c'était quelqu'un qui faisait la
préparation psychologique si on roule
donc son but à lui 7 2 nous amener à la
performance mois
je pensais que c'était une personne de
confiance que je me confiait à cette
personne-là cette personne le alley
divulguer l'information aux dirigeants
puis au coach pour y être et ça je
recevais des sanctions
après avoir pris sa retraite du patinage
courte piste en 2012 antoine
gélinas-beaulieu a passé des années à
voyager et à chercher des réponses
dans le monde du sport c'est pas facile
de 1,2 se montrer vulnérable puis de se
poser ces questions-là le thé
puis d'aller chercher de l'aide aussi
souvent on a l'impression qu'il faut
qu'on reste forte il faut qu'on regarde
la face ou que mais on sait son 6e l'on
parle a pas grand monde qui ont vu
naître des pressions dans notre coin
c'est dans la
santé
en 2015 il s'est joint à l'équipe de
patinage de vitesse sur longue piste
avec un nouveau coach
avec gregor c'était complètement
différent s'il m'écoutait il ya la mort
il laissé beaucoup d'espacé très
apathique et
pourtant lorsqu'antoine se retrouver sur
la glace les symptômes d'anxiété ramener
le hanter
détonne d'études font clairement le lien
entre le fait d'avoir été victimes de
violences psychologiques et les
problèmes de santé mentale
ça peut prendre la forme d'anxiété de
dépression de conflits interpersonnels
de troubles alimentaires ou d'idées
suicidaires
on commence tout juste à étudier ces
questions dans le monde du sport
je crois qu'il faut remettre les
compteurs à zéro
il faut changer la culture dans le monde
du sport il revoir ses structures
le sport dans ce pays est géré de façon
autonome les fédérations ne répondent
pas aux normes qui existe ailleurs dans
la société existe entre acteurs et
surtout pas si les professeurs à l'école
se comportait comme certains entraîneurs
les conséquences seraient très
différentes
la chercheuse suggère de
professionnaliser le métier d'entraîneur
en imposant des formations et en
instaurant une organismes de
réglementation autrement les coaches qui
sont souvent dans ces athlètes risquent
de reproduire ce qu'ils ont subi
elle a commencé à travailler avec
l'association des entraîneurs de
l'ontario elle leur enseigne à motiver
les athlètes autrement qu en les
punissant ou à promouvoir la forme
physique sans dénigrer l'apparence de
quiconque
antoine gélinas-beaulieu a
tranquillement repris confiance en lui
il est allé chercher de l'aide
il a appris à gérer ces symptômes
d'anxiété et de dépression
ça a été long je dirais mais tellement
nécessaire parce que non seulement oui
le père forme mais je suis heureux le
présente plus je planais 4 et chaque
course je tire bien les émotions en
décembre dernier et s'est qualifiée pour
les jeux olympiques a voulu qu'on qu'il
est plus bas à bejing il ne compte pas
courir pour les médailles ou pour les
autres il ne fera pour lui pour le
plaisir de la compétition de la vitesse
qu'il a enfin retrouvé qu'un jour être
sur la ligne de départ aux jeux
olympiques leur propre aux malades